いや、ほんとにね、俺もね、今回はねぇ もうホントにね俺が悪かった
もう・・・ほんとに
でも、完璧に銀行にはちゃんと今日行って
記帳したから・・・もうそれに全・・・ン・・あの・・
集中力を注いでしまって、ちょっとね・・え？
「。、。、。、。」
はい。あぁ
「、。、。、。、。、。、。、。、。、。、。」
全部無い、今
すいません。許してください。うぅ僕が悪かったです
「、。。。、。。、、。、。、」
ゆうちょの通帳かー、俺さゆうちょの通帳かーさんに渡したっけ？
でしょ！？  ああもうお金無いよ。。 あﾊｰﾊｰ・・お母さん、 お金無いよおお
何もない、今日の夜ご飯も食べれない‥
あ、大丈夫、流石にそんな・・・
それはね、まじダメダメ
無賃乗車はダメ
ヒッチハイク！  その手があるな。
ｔｔｔ一回やってみたかったそれは
通帳もないもんね・・分りましたすいません、ホントにそれは申し訳ないです、はい分りました、気を付けます、すいません
すいませんでした、ほんとにもう、ほんとに申し訳ございませんでした、はい、あー分りましたすいませんあーわかりました、すいません明日学校
いや、学校は行くよ？ちゃんと
俺もふざけてこんな事やってる訳じゃないんスよぉ
はい解りましたJYO頑張ってみます、すいません
はぁい！　お休みなさい、失礼しまーす
あはぁはぁはぁ・・あああはぁーーーこんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
はい！と言う訳でやって参りました、今月はたっくさんイベントが有りました。
先ずはですね、えっと、すべてのイベントにですね参加してくださった皆様、ほんとにありがとうございます
あのぉぉ、今日の動画は先ずはそのイベントの感謝の気持ちを伝える事と、
ちょっと、今月の僕のスケジュールが多分人生の内で最も激しいと、思われるので、ﾁｮｯﾄね
近況報告の動画になります、はい
先ずはですね、えーとイベント！ 　ユーチューブ　ファン　フェスト
そしてその後になった、ｳｰﾑ。僕の事務所のイベント、ユーフェス
そして、２３日にあった、埼玉スーパーアリーナであった、ティーンズ　コレクション　に来て下さった皆様・・・
ホントに、ありがとうございました
ホントに皆さんのね、えと、応援とか声援が無ければ僕はもうね、やってらんないっすよ
いや、やって･･･やります、それはやりますけど
やりますけど、ほんとに皆さんの声援が有って僕は何とかやっております。
ホントに来て下さった皆様ありがとうございます
いやぁ～　盛り上がってるね
はい、ほんとにね、会場の方は盛り上がってとても良かったです
どっちかってと喋り系、ＭＣとかそっちの方が多かったのでね
あの～、喋るのが苦手な僕にとってはとても勉強になる、いい機会でした
ほんとにね、その様な機会を与えて下さった皆さまに感謝しております
ありがとうございます
で！！　ここから何ですけども、今の俺の状況の説明に入る
取りあえずですね、僕に、大きなミッションが実はありまして
通帳を記帳しなければいけなかったんです
もうね、これはね、ほんとにマスト
通帳の記帳を怠たるとですねなんか
色々と、諸問題が起きてしまう様で、マミーがね、マジで、ホントにお前マジで通帳記帳しろって事を前から、前から、前から、ずーっと言ってたんですけども、
ようやくちょっとね、静岡でゆっくりできる時間が出来た。
通帳の記帳に行ったんですけども
それはね、絶対忘れちゃダメだと思って頑張って覚えてて、
銀行には行けたんですよ。ミッション、クリア
そこは大丈夫だったんですけども、そこに気を取られ過ぎてて、財布を紛失してしまいました。
すいませんでした
僕は今
お金が有りません
東京から静岡に帰ってきて、で、そのまま、その乗った、新幹線が、そのまま行っちゃった訳ですよ
大阪の方まで新幹線が行っちゃって
なんで今、僕の財布は～新大阪駅にあります
いや、笑えねーよ。
何で、俺もう何かネタじゃ、ネタでやってるわけじゃないんすよ。
なんで、ネタで大阪まで財布を届けにゃいけないんすか？
いや、でも、今月俺、頑張ったよ
イベントたくさん出たし、その中でもなんやかんや動画をちょこちょこ出してるし
もうね、財布を忘れるぐらいの事はやって来たと思ってる
何かを成し遂げる為には、何かを失わなければいけないんで
ま、その一つとして今僕の財布が犠牲になったと、思っております
で、財布の方はですね、無事新大阪駅で新幹線の中で無事財布は見つかったみたいなんで
財布の方は確保されているのでそこは安心なんですけども
新大阪の方から僕んちまで郵送されるんで
その届くしばらくの間は僕はお金が有りません
そこで僕はいち早く、お金を手に入れなきゃ、と思って、
通帳でお金を銀行から下ろそうと思ったんですけども
通帳がですね、今色々訳が有って実家の方に置いていて、僕には今お金を降ろす、お金を手に入れる手段が有りません。
という状況の中、なんと、なーんとですね、明日からまた、東京に行くことになりました。
よっ！
へっへっへっへっ・・・はっはっはっはっ・・・はっはっはっはっはっ・・・ふゅーっ
もう東京ヤバいよ。
静岡東京静岡東京静岡東京のパターンですよ、完全に
もうね、もう…トコロ、どこに行けばいいの俺は、
自分の住んでる所が分んないひっひっひっひっひっひっひっへぇ゛ーへぇ゛へへっへへ
と言う感じでですね、ちょっと財布が無いんですけども何とかして
とりあえず、こっからね、どうやって明日東京に行こうかって話になってるんですよ今。
友達に連絡したんですけど、友達が今お金が五千円しかないって言ってるんで借りれ無さそうだった
まずいなー。
取りあえずですね、そのーイベントがひと段落したのと、ホントに来てくださった皆様。本当にありがとうございました。
そして、JRの僕の財布を見つけて下さった駅員の方。本当にありがとうございました。
免許証も、保険証もクレジットも全部入ってるので
あれが、誰かに捕られると、僕はもう人ではなくなっていました。ほんとにありがとうございました。
お金も全部ないし、自分の時間もないんですけども、僕は、皆さんに支えられて今を生きております。
全ての人に感謝して、
I can fight！